NOW, WE ARE GOING THROUGH
THAT'S OUR BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
IN MY HANDS BRAND NEW AT
THIS HOUR BOMBSHELL
REVELATIONS FROM THE
GRASSLEY MEMO.
MAJOR PARTS FROM THE MEMO
FROM YESTERDAY HAVE NOW BEEN
UNREDACTED.
HUGE PARTS YESTERDAY.
MEMO FURTHER
MEMO PURTHER
MEMO PROTHER
MEMO PROVIER
MEMO PROVIDING FURTHER
EVIDENCE THAT THE FISA COURT
WAS LIED TO IN ORDER TO GET
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE MAY HAVE
LIED TO THE FBI ABOUT
BRIEFING MEDIA OUTLETS THERE
IS A LOT TO COVER.
WE ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH
IT SLOWLY.
WE WILL DO IT TOGETHER.
NOW THE MEMO STARTS WITH
THIS.
THIS IS PAGE ONE OF THE MEMO
RIGHT HERE.
ON THE FACE, THE DOSSIER, IT
APPEARS THAT MR. STEELE
GOVERNMENT SOURCES INSIDE OF
RUSSIA.
AND, ACCORDING TO THE LAW
FIRM PERKINS COIE,
MR. STEELE'S DOSSIER EFFORTS
WERE FUNDED THROUGH FUSION
GPS BY THAT LAW FIRM ON
BEHALF OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
LET'S PAUSE HERE.
HILLARY CLINTON IS PAYING
STEELE TO SPREAD RUSSIAN
LIES AND RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
I WILL READ IT AGAIN BECAUSE
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
INSIDE OF RUSSIA.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THE MEDIA
HERE?
OH, SO, KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD.
MR. STEELE LIED TO THE FBI
OR TO THE BRITISH COURT THAT
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
WERE VIEWED BY THE COMMITTEE
CONTAIN MATERIALLY FALSE
STATEMENTS.
AND THEN THE MEMO GOES ON TO
READ IN SPHAWNS TO THE
COMMITTEE'S INQUIRIES, THE
CHAIRMAN AND RANKING MEMBER
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
THEN THE MEMO GOES ON TO SAY
THAT BRIEFING AGRESSED THE
WITH MR. STEELE AND THE
FBI'S RELIANCE ON
MR. STEELE'S DOSSIER IN TWO
APPLICATIONS THAT IT FILED
FOR SURVEILLANCE UNDER THE
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE ACT.
THEN, MARCH 17TH, 2017, THE
CHAIRMAN AND RANKING MEMBER
WERE PROVIDED COPIES OF THE
TWO RELEVANT FISA
APPLICATIONS WHICH REQUESTED
AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT
SURVEILLANCE OF CARTER PAGE.
BOTH RELIED HEAVILY ON
MR. STEELE'S DOSSIER CLAIMS
AND BOTH APPLICATIONS WERE
GRANTED BY THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE COURT.
IN DECEMBER 2017, THE
CHAIRMAN, RANKING MEMBER AND
FISA APPLICATIONS RELIES ON
THE DOSSIER TO SEEK
SURVEILLANCE OF MR. CARTER
NOW, THE NEXT PARAGRAPH,
THIS IS INTERESTING.
I WONDER WHAT'S IN THAT.
THEN THE FOLLOWING BRAFF,
PARAGRAPH, FOLLOW ALONG,
SIMILARLY IN JUNE OF 2017
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
COMEY TESTIFIED PUBLICLY
BEFORE THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON INTELLIGENCE THAT HE HAD
BRIEFED PRESIDENT-ELECT
TRUMP ON THE DOSSIER'S
ALLEGATIONS IN JANUARY, WHEN
HE WAS PRESIDENT-ELECT, JUST
BEFORE HE WAS SWORN INTO
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP AS
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
WHEN ASKED AT THE MARCH 2017
BRIEFING WHY THE FBI THEN
RELIED ON THE DOSSIER IN THE
FISA APPLICATIONS ABSENT
MEANINGFUL COOPERATION IN
LIGHT OF THE HIGHLY
POLITICAL MOTIVE SURROUNDING
ITS CREATION, THEN DIRECTOR
COMEY STATED THE FBI
INCLUDED ALLEGATIONS ABOUT
THE CARTER PAGE IN THE FISA
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE
MR. STEELE HIMSELF WAS
CONSIDERED RELIABLE DUE TO
HIS PAST WORK WITH THE FBI.
NOW, LATER ON THAT PAGE,
BULK OF THE FISA
APPLICATION, PUT THAT BACK
UP ON THE SCREEN, CONSISTS
OF ALLEGATIONS AGAINST PAGE
THAT WERE DISCLOSED TO THE
FBI BY MR. STEELE AND ALSO
OUTLINED IN THE STEELE
CONTAIN NO ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION, CORROBORATING
THE DOSSIER AGENCIES ALLEGATIONS
MR. PAGE ALTHOUGH IT DOES
CITE TO A NEWS ARTICLE THAT
APPEARS TO SOURCE
MR. STEELE'S DOSSIER.
LET'S STOP RIGHT HERE.
THE ENTIRE BULK OF THE FISA
APPLICATION CAME FROM THE
DOSSIER.
BEING PAID BY THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND BY THE DNC,
FUNNELING THE MONEY, FUSION
GPS GOT THE MONEY THROUGH
THE LAW FIRM, BOTH THE DNC
AND THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
USED.
THERE WAS NO VERIFICATION OF
ANY OF THIS.
IT WAS JUST BASED ON THE
DOSSIER.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY SAY
WELL, HE WAS LEE LIABLE IN
THE PAST.
AND THEN IMAGINE THIS, IN
OCTOBER, WHEN THEY FILED FOR
THE FIRST APPLICATION FOR
FISA AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, WELL, THREE MONTHS
LATER IN JANUARY, JAMES
COMEY IS SAYING THAT IT'S
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
AND PRESENT IT AS THE BULK
OF EVIDENCE?
DO YOU SEE WHERE WE ARE
GOING HERE?
NOW, HERE IS WHAT PAGE 3 OF
PROVIDED BY MR. STEELE IN
FOOTNOTES 8 AND 18 OF THE
FISA WARRANT APPLICATION.
THE FBI NOTED A VAGUELY
LIMITED EXTENT THE POLITICAL
ORIGINS OF THE DOSSIER.
STOP RIGHT THERE.
THEY KNEW IT WAS FUNDED BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE FISA
COURT THAT IMPORTANT PIECE
OF INFORMATION.
I THINK THE FISA COURT
THIS IS THE BULK OF THEIR
CASE.
THE DOSSIER, IF IT WAS
COMING FROM ONE CAMPAIGN
AGAINST ANOTHER CAMPAIGN IN
THE LEAD UP TO AN ELECTION.
NOW, IN FOOTNOTE 8 THE FBI
STATED THE DOSSIER
INFORMATION WAS COMPILED
PURSUANT TO THE DIRECTION OF
A LAW FIRM WHO HAD HIRED AND
IDENTIFIED U.S. PERSON NOW
APPLICATION FAILED TO
DISCLOSE THAT THE IDENTITIES
OF MR. SIMPSON'S ULTIMATE
WHY WOULD THE FBI, IN MAKING
A FISA APPLICATION, AGAINST
AN OPPOSITION PARTY IN AN
ELECTION YEAR AND KNOWING
IT'S PAID FOR BY THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC, WHY
WOULD THEY NOT TELL THE FISA
COURT JUDGE?
THAT, TO ME, IS A SERIOUS
OMISSION.
AND ONE THAT STATES THERE IS
A POLITICAL MOTIVE BEHIND
ALL OF THIS.
NOW, LET'S JUST GO BACK A
LITTLE FURTHER.
SAME FBI THAT, IN FACT, IN
SPITE OF A MOUNTAIN OF
EVIDENCE, THAT HILLARY
CLINTON MISHANDLED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
DESTROYED AND DELETED 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS AND THEN
USED ACID WASH AND THEN
BLEACH BIT AND THEN BUSTED
UP, YOU KNOW, DIFFERENT
DEVICES WITH HAMMERS.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT KEPT
HER IN THE RACE ARE NOW
WORKING ON HER BEHALF AGAIN.
AND THEY ARE DOING IT IN
THIS CASE BY NOT TELLING THE
WE CONTINUE.
THE FBI STATED TO THE FISA
RELIABLE INFORMATION TO THE
FBI, THE FBI BELIEVES
STEELE'S REPORTING TO BE
CREDIBLE.
IN SHORT, IT APPEARS THE FBI
RELIED ON ADMITTEDLY
UNCORROBORATED INFORMATION
FUNDED BY AND OBTAINED FOR
SECRETARY CLINTON WANTS
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IN
ORDER TO CONDUCT
SURVEILLANCE OF AN ASSOCIATE
OF AN OPPOSING PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
THESE ARE -- THIS IS RIGHT
HERE IN THIS -- RIGHT HERE.
IT DID SO BASED ON
MR. STEELE'S PERSONAL
CREDIBILITY AND PRESUMABLY
WOW.
THEY DIDN'T TELL THE
COURTNEY OF THIS?
THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT
WHERE THE MONEY CAME FROM?
THEY ALSO KNEW AT THAT TIME
THAT THAT STEELE HATED TRUMP
BECAUSE TRUMP -- BECAUSE
STEELE MENTIONED IT TO BRUCE
OHR.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A
MINUTE.
THERE IS SUBSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE THAT ARE MR. STEELE
MATERIALLY MISLEAD THE FBI
ARTICLE DATED
SEPTEMBER 23RD, 2016, WHICH
IN PARTICULAR CONTAINED SOME
OF THE SAME DOSSIER
INFORMATION ABOUT MR. PAGE
COMPILED BY MR. STEELE ON
WHICH THE FBI RELIED ON IN
ITS APPLICATION.
WHILE NOT EXPLICITLY STATED,
THIS IS PRESUMABLY THE
ARTICLE WRITTEN BY MICHAEL
ISIKOFF ENTITLED U.S. INTEL
OFFICIALS PRO-TIES BETWEEN
TRUMP ADVISOR AND KREMLIN.
WE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACTED THE
APPLICATION, ATTEMPTS TO
EXPLAIN AWAY THE
INCONSISTENCY BETWEEN
STEELE'S ASSERTION TO THE
MR. STEELE'S CREDIBILITY ON
WHICH IT STILL RELIED ON THE
RENEWAL REQUEST OF THE FISA
APPLICATION.
HAVE YOU GOT TO RENEW IT
EVERY 90 DAYS.
IT SAID GIVEN THAT THE
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
SEPTEMBER 23RD NEWS ARTICLE
GENERALLY MATCHES THE
INFORMATION ABOUT PAGE, THAT
STEELE DISCOVERED, DOING
HIRST/HER RESEARCH REDACTED.
STOP FOR A SECOND.
LIKE THEY ARE TWO SEPARATE
YET CORROBORATING PIECES OF
INFORMATION TO PUT EMPHASIS
TO THE COURT, OH, SEE, WE
HAVE GOT TWO SOURCES.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THE
SOURCE OF THE YAHOO NEWS
ARTICLE IS THE SAME SOURCE
OF THE DOSSIER, SAME GUY
DIDN'T WANT TRUMP TO WIN AND
SAME GUY BEING PAID BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS SO CORRUPT.
AND HERE'S WHAT'S ON PAGE 4.
GOT IT RIGHT HERE, ALL OF
THIS RIGHT HERE.
IN FOOTNOTE 9 OF ITS
JANUARY 2017 APPLICATION,
THIS IS THE FIRST RENEWAL OF
THE FISA WARRANT IN THIS
CASE FOR MR. PAGE, THE FBI
AGAIN ADDRESSED MR. STEELE'S
REMEMBER, THAT'S THE SAME
JANUARY WHERE JAMES COMEY
TOLD PRESIDENT TRUMP IT'S
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
BACK TO THE DOCUMENT.
THE FBI NOTED THAT IT HAD
SUSPENDED THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH MR. STEELE IN OCTOBER
OF 2016 BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION TO THE PRESS.
NOW, THE FBI RELAYED THAT
STEELE HAD BEEN BOTHERED BY
THE FBI'S NOTIFICATION TO
CONGRESS IN OCTOBER OF 2016
ABOUT THE REOPENING OF THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
REMEMBER THAT HAPPENED JUST
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
AND AS A RESULT, STEELE
INDEPENDENTLY AND AGAINST
PRIOR ADMONISHMENT TO THE
FBI TO SPEAK ONLY WITH THE
FBI ON THIS MATTER RELEASED
THE RECORDING DISCUSSED
HEREIN.
DOSSIER ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
PAGE TO AN IDENTIFIED NEWS
ORGANIZATION.
HOWEVER, THE FBI CONTINUED
TO STILL CITE MR. STEELE'S
PAST WORK AS EVIDENCE THREE
MONTHS LATER OF HIS
RELIABILITY.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY ARE
TELLING DONALD TRUMP IT'S
UNVERIFIED.
TO THE FBI SUSPENDING THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH MR. STEELE
APPLICATION.
NOW, THE FBI FURTHER
ASSERTED IN FOOTNOTE 19 THAT
IT DID NOT BELIEVE THAT
STEELE DIRECTLY GAVE
INFORMATION TO YAHOO NEWS
THAT PUBLISHED THE
SEPTEMBER 23RD NEWS ARTICLE.
NOW, IN THE NEXT PARAGRAPH,
THIS IS WHAT IT READS.
IN DEFENDING MR. STEELE'S
CREDIBILITY, TO THE FISA
COURT, THE FBI HAD POSTED AN
INNOCUOUS EXPLANATION FOR
THE SEPTEMBER 23RD ARTICLE
BASED ON THE ASSUMPTION THAT
MR. STEELE HAD TOLD THE FINN
THE TRUTH ABOUT HIS PRESS
USING THE SAME RATIONALE IN
SUBSEQUENT RENEWAL
APPLICATIONS, YOU KNOW,
FILED WITH THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE
NOW, HERE'S THE IMPORTANT
PART OF PAGE 5.
THE FIRST OF THESE FILINGS
WAS PUBLICLY REPORTED IN THE
U.S. MEDIA IN APRIL OF 2017.
INSTEAD, THE APPLICATION
STILL RELIED PRIMARILY,
REMEMBER, THE BULK OF THE
APPLICATION IS THE FIRESTONE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
THE APPLICATION STILL, WE
ARE SIX MONTHS INTO THIS
THING, RELIED ON HIS
CREDIBILITY EVEN THOUGH THE
FBI KNEW HE WAS NOT
CREDIBILITY AT THIS POINT.
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
WAY IN OCTOBER, THE SAME
MONTH THE FIRST FISA WARRANT
WAS GRANTED.
NOW, HERE'S WHAT'S ON PAGE
6.
WHETHER MR. STEELE LIED TO
THE FINN ABOUT HIS MEDIA
CONTACTS IS RELEVANT FOR AT
LEAST TWO REASONS.
FIRST, IT'S RELEVANT TO HIS
OF CORROBORATION FOR HIS
CLAIMS, AT LEAST AT THE TIME
THEY WERE INCLUDED IN THE
FISA APPLICATIONS.
SECOND, IT T. IS RELEVANT TO
THE RELIABILITY OF THE
INFORMATION-GATHERING
EFFORTS.
MR. STEELE CONVICTED HIS
WORK FOR FUSION GPS,
COMPILING THE PREELECTION
NOW, THERE WAS THIS BRITISH
LITIGATION.
THERE IS TALKS ABOUT IT IN
THE GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM MEMO
HERE TONIGHT.
MR. STEELE ACKNOWLEDGED
BRIEFING JOURNALISTS ABOUT
THE DOSSIER MEMORANDUM IN
LATE SUMMER, AUTUMN 2016.
YEAH, HE WAS A SOURCE FOR
ISIKOFF.
SURPRISINGLY, DURING THE
SUMMER OF 2016, REPORTS OF
AT LEAST SOME OF THE DOSSIER
REPORTERS.
ADMITTED IN THE LITIGATION
BRIEFING JOURNALISTS IN THE
YAHOO, NEW YORKER, THE FAKE
NETWORK CNN NOVEMBER OF
2016.
MORE PEOPLE WHO
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY KNEW THAT
MR. STEELE WAS COMPILING HIS
MANIPULATION.
IN FACT, IN THE BRITISH
LITIGATION, WHICH INVOLVES A
POST ELECTION DOSSIER
MEMORANDUM, STEELE ADMITTED
THAT HE HAD RECEIVED AND
INCLUDED IT.
THAT FILING IMPLIES THAT HE
SIMILARLY RECEIVED
UNSOLICITED INTELLIGENCE ON
THESE MATTERS PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION AS WELL STATING
THAT MR. STEELE CONTINUED TO
RECEIVE UNSOLICITED
INTELLIGENCE, NOW, PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION, ON MATTERS
COVERED BY THE PREELECTION
MEMORANDUM AFTER THE U.S.
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
NOW, THE NEXT PARAGRAPH IS
REDACTED.
IT GOES ON.
ONE MEMORANDUM ON MR. STEELE
THAT WAS NOT PUBLISHED BY
BUZZFEED IS DATED
OCTOBER 19, 2016.
THE REPORT ALLEGES REDACTED
AS WELL REDACTED,
MR. STEELE'S MEMORANDUM
STATES THAT HIS COMPANY
RECEIVED THIS REPORT
REDACTED, U.S. STATE
DEPARTMENT.
THAT THE REPORT WAS THE
SECOND IN A SERIES.
AND THAT THE REPORT, PAY
TOUCH WITH, REDACTED, A
CONTACT OF REDACTED, A
I WOULD LOVE THE REDACTS
HERE.
TROUBLE ENOUGH THAT FUNDED
STEELEENS WORK.
THE CLINTON ASSOCIATE AS WE
REPORTED LAST NIGHT CON
THIS RAISES ADDITIONAL
CONCERN ABOUT HIS
CREDIBILITY.
LET'S HEAD TO PAGE 7.
FBI'S ASSERTIONS IN ITS
INITIAL APPLICATION IN
OCTOBER OF 2016 FOR THE FISA
WARRANT AS WELL AS
SUBSEQUENT RENEWAL
APPLICATIONS.
THE FBI REPEATEDLY
REPRESENTED TO THE FISA
COURT THAT MR. STEELE TOLD
THE FBI HE DID NOT HAVE
UNAUTHORIZED CONTACTS WITH
THE PRESS ABOUT THE DOSSIER
PRIOR TO OCTOBER 2016.
THE CONTEXT OF THE
SEPTEMBER 2016 YAHOO NEWS
ARTICLE, BUT MR. STEELE HAS
HAVE SOME CONTACTS WITH THE
PRESS AT THIS TIME AND HIS
FORMER BUSINESS PARTNER
MR. SIMPSON HAD CONFIRMED IT
TO THE COMMITTEE.
THUS, THE FISA APPLICATIONS
ARE EITHER MATERIALLY FALSE
IN CLAIMING THAT MR. STEELE
SAID DID HE NOT PROVIDE
DOSSIER INFORMATION TO THE
PRESS PRIOR TO OCTOBER 2016
OR MR. STEELE MADE
MATERIALLY FALSE STATEMENTS
THAT THE FBI WHEN HE CLAIMED
HE ONLY PROVIDED THE DOSSIER
INFORMATION TO HIS BUSINESS
PARTNER AND THE FBI.
AND PAGE 7 CONTINUES.
IN THIS CASE, STEELE'S
APPARENT DECEPTION SEEMS TO
HAVE POSED SIGNIFICANT
MATERIAL CONSEQUENCES ON THE
FBI'S INVESTIGATIVE DECISION
AND REPRESENTATIONS TO THE
FISA COURT AND STEELE'S
INFORMATION WILL FORMED A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
FBI, FISA APPLICATION RELIED
MORE HEAVILY ON STEELE'S
CREDIBILITY THAN ON ANY
INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION OR
CORROBORATION FOR HIS
WARRANT AUTHORIZING
SURVEILLANCE ON A U.S.
CITIZEN LARGELY RESTS ON
MR. STEELE'S CREDIBILITY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
TO DETERMINE WHETHER
MR. STEELE PROVIDED FALSE
INFORMATION TO THE FBI AND
WHETHER THE FBI'S